hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 32 hört zu und
spricht nach halo lisa hallo maria wie
geht's hallo maria wie geht es gut danke
und dir gut danke und dir auch gut
was hast du am wochenende gemacht auch
gut
was hast du am wochenende gemacht ich
habe gitarre gespielt
ich habe gitarre gespielt
am samstag bin ich mit meinem freund in
den bergen gewandert
den bergen gewandert ich habe die schöne
landschaft fotografiert ich habe die
schöne landschaft fotografiert am
sonntag war putztag am sonntag war
putztag ich habe das ganze haus geputzt
ich habe das ganze haus geputzt garten
habe ich den rasen gemäht garten habe
ich den rasen gemäht und du was hast du
gemacht und du was hast du gemacht
also am freitag war ich sehr müde
ich habe gewartet
ich habe gewartet und dann habe ich mich
auf das sofa gelegt und dann habe ich
mich auf das sofa gelegt ich habe eine
pizza bestellt und noch einen film
geschaut
ich habe eine pizza bestellt und noch
einen film geschaut
am samstag habe ich im supermarkt
lebensmittel eingekauft am samstag habe
ich im supermarkt lebensmittel
eingekauft
dann habe ich ein bild gemalt dann habe
ich ein bild gemalt und am abend habe
ich in der disco getanzt und am abend
habe ich in der disco getanzt
katrin und dominik kommt bitte kurz
kathrin und dominik kommt bitte kurz so
geht es nicht weiter wir müssen unsere
wg hausarbeiten neu aufteilen und einen
ähnlichen plan aufstellen
so geht es nicht weiter wir müssen
unsere wg hausarbeiten neu aufteilen und
einen plan aufstellen
ich habe diese woche jeden tag gekocht
und die lebensmittel eingekauft ich habe
diese woche jeden tag gekocht und die
lebensmittel eingekauft das hat sehr
viel zeit in anspruch genommen ich muss
für mein studium lernen das hat sehr
für mein studium lernen ja aber du
kochst doch gern
ja aber du kochst doch gern
ja das stimmt schon aber trotzdem ist es
sehr zeitintensiv ja das stimmt schon
aber trotzdem ist es sehr zeitintensiv
ich habe das geschirr india
waschmaschine geräumt und dann auch
wieder ausgeräumt
ich habe das geschirr in die abwasch
maschine geräumt und danach wieder
ausgeräumt
ich habe auch den müll rausgebracht ich
habe auch den müll rausgebracht
ich habe am montag die ganze wohnung
geputzt
das hat zwei stunden gedauert ich habe
am montag die ganze wohnung geputzt
das hat zwei stunden gedauert das bad
war sehr schmutzig das ist keine arbeit
die mir spaß macht das bad war sehr
schmutzig das ist keine arbeit die mir
spaß macht
trotzdem ich hatte zirka acht stunden
aufwand und ihr viel weniger dominik was
hast du noch gemacht hast du nur das
geschehe rein und ausgeräumt und den
müll rausgebracht
dominik was hast du noch gemacht hast du
nur das geschehe rein und ausgeräumt und
den müll rausgebracht
also fuhr gestern habe ich das
waschbecken repariert das könnt ihr
nicht
also fuhr gestern habe ich das
waschbecken repariert das könnt ihr
nicht
daran habe ich auch mindestens eine
stunde gearbeitet
aha deshalb ist das bad schon wieder
schmutzig aha deshalb ist das bad schon
wieder schmutzig nein das kann nicht
sein
ich habe nach den boden gewischt nein
das kann nicht sein
ich habe nach den boden gewischt
außerdem habe ich gestern im wohnzimmer
auch staub gesaugt außerdem habe ich
gestern im wohnzimmer auch staub gesaugt
und show
ich habe deine hemden gebügelt also was
soll das und show
soll das wir machen alle etwa gleich
viele hausarbeiten
aber das finde ich gar nicht ich habe
ich putze die wohnung ich putze die
wohnung
ich habe die wohnung geputzt
ich habe gestern die wohnung geputzt
ich habe am dienstag die wohnung geputzt
ich habe letzte woche die wohnung
geputzt
ich habe vor einer stunde die wohnung
ich habe vor
der stunde die wohnung geputzt ich habe
vor einer stunde die zähne geputzt
ich habe vor einer stunde die zähne
geputzt
ich habe vor eine stunde den boden
ich habe vor einer stunde den boden
geputzt
hast du gestern fußball gespielt hast du
gestern fußball gespielt hast du gestern
basketball gespielt hast du gestern
basketball gespielt hast du schon einmal
golf gespielt hast du schon einmal golf
gespielt hast du schon einmal tennis
gespielt er hat im supermarkt eingekauft
er hat im supermarkt eingekauft
er hat
letzte woche im supermarkt eingekauft er
hat letzte woche im supermarkt
eingekauft
er hat für das abendessen eingekauft er
hat für das abendessen eingekauft er hat
für das abendessen die lebensmittel
eingekauft
er hat
abendessen die lebensmittel eingekauft
habt ihr die hausaufgaben gemacht habt
ihr die hausaufgaben gemacht habt ihr
die hausaufgaben schon gemacht habt ihr
gearbeitet habt ihr gearbeitet habt ihr
gestern gearbeitet habt ihr gestern
gearbeitet wie lange habt ihr gestern
gearbeitet wie lange habt ihr gestern im
büro gearbeitet wie lange habt ihr
gestern im büro gearbeitet
sie haben
pizza bestellt sie haben eine pizza
bestellt sie haben vor einer stunde eine
pizza bestellt sie haben vor einer
stunde eine pizza bestellt möchtest du
noch weitere videos sehen dann abonniere
unseren kanal jeden sonntag ein neues
video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video